hallo leute ich es wieder eure wahl paar
mal war mein name ist mal über hallo
leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne und
heute und willkommen zu einem neuen wie
schmeckt nur hallo leute ich es wieder
eure mal wasser und bekommen zu einer
neuen folge wie schmeckt heute machen
wir den pizzabäcker burger aus tv total
da gibt es nämlich eine folge wo espaces
und dem pizzabäcker bürger mitbringen
und ja ich sagte mir das auf dem foto
tal ist damit dieses format weiterhin
sinn macht eigentlich mache ich heute
den pizzabäcker bürger von den spam aus
tv total und es fragt ihr euch über
vanessa warum kommst du was von youtuber
nach weil die spaceys auf ihrem kanal
meine krabben burger pizza gemacht haben
und dann dachte ich das kann ich auch
also hoffen aber den vorbei und wenn ihr
von denen gerade kommt hey ich bin
vanessa abonniert main kanal und jetzt
fangen wir am donnerstag
pizzabäcker pegel von ins bettchen
färbung leute eine eigene kreation pizza
burger und nicht diesen scheiß bisher
aus der werbung etwas bessere stelle ist
pizza burger beck immer alle schritte
von dem video nach den jungs sind wie
ich und schreiben keine rezepte in die
infobox
da muss man dann das video schaut
während man kocht danke kommen wir zu
den zutaten mehl olivenöl was passierte
thomas fleisch vegetarisch sagt ganz
schön viel käse um es mit den worten von
steve zusagen zeug zum drauflegen und
gewürzt als erstes macht break mehl in
eine schüssel und steve soll stopp sagen
und er sagt bei 400 gramm stopp alter
nehmen die vier mit grambin stadtgrabens
voll unfair die spaceys können immer
zusammen videos drehen
ich muss da sagst du stark ja klar
amsterdam gewannen
das sind 400 gramm mehl josi misst sagen
wie viel was er hier einmal wir schätzen
einfach mal die mengenangabe ist
olivenöl die mengenangabe ist hau rein
jetzt kommt salz in den teig und etwas
pfeffer macht man den teig mit dem tag
macht man doch kein fett weg was ist das
jetzt kommt das geilste ich frage mich
aber warum keine hefe im teig ist weil
es doch ein pizzabäcker burger und pins
datei kann es doch einfach bis dann hebt
und damit das gewicht wird möchte auch
nicht so ein blöder besserwisser seiner
ware kannst du da nicht ein bisschen was
vergessen olivenöl ist doch typisch
warum hast du bekommst junge vielleicht
in seiner eltern lehrern einem hefe
unfall gestorben und deswegen benutzer
seitdem keine hebel mehr um ein gott der
pizzabäcker bürger macht mir den humor
zur strafe muss ich in die saure miene
das wird der teig erst steinhart und
riecht nach pfeffer sorry ich verstehe
nur nicht behaupten dann kein weg machen
wir mal weiter tomatensoße dazu muss man
die tomaten schneiden
wichtig ist ganze tomaten werden hier in
kleine stücke und passiert also
letztlich passierte tomaten in eine
schüssel jemand tomatensuppe jetzt nach
salz pfeffer und oregano in meinem fall
basilikum und dann miteinander verrühren
what's next diesen käse werden wir zum
praktische wirklich für das fleisch
schneiden
ich wünschte ich könnte hier schneiden
in diesem jahr sind praktische würfel
für das fleisch so glückliches
vegetarisches hat man von nicht tot ist
so 'ne geile konsistenten okay wir
machen jetzt einen fleisch trinkt muss
jetzt einmal müssen springen ich muss
jetzt den teig ausrollen weil ich muss
diesen ring auf dem teig machen weil ich
keinen
beraten werde weil das halt schon
gebraten ist diesen tagen muss mit
ausrollen und dafür benutze ich vix
video magie und großteil geworden jetzt
machen wir den hackfleisch kreistitel
von seiner sekte so sollte es aussehen
nach dem hackfleisch kreis machen wir
ein geschichte peter drauf und dann
kommt er nochmal strauß das klingt schon
nach einem rezept von den space box
großes basics was macht ihr dann aber
die traditionsklubs gewürzregal
menstruationsblut haha und die
tomatensoße lecker als nächstes kommt
salami oben drauf dann habe ich
natürlich auch gedacht wie schmeckt
vegetarische salami zwei oscars wie sie
den salami geschmack da rein kriegen
es sieht immer besser aus okay danach
kommt ein riesensprung und sie haben
tomaten zwiebeln und paprika
draufgemacht ich sag mal tomate tomate
meine oma kann karate
das war wie eine blume straße bis zum 8
zwiebeln drauf und nun folgt der käse
lisa doby jetzt müssen wir den teig
rumheulen ich hoffe ihr seht war ich
mach mal ein bisschen scharf hier ich
versuche jetzt die zeit rum zu rollen
der wird richtig gut damit steche ich
jetzt nämlich die mitte aus zwei die
parteien spaceys so sieht ein bitter
regel aus
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt da noch tomatensoße und
käse drauf das ist ein liter becken
donath weil es die vegetarische version
edeka will deswegen muss jetzt in den
ofen ich weiß nicht wie lange oder bei
welcher temperatur ich mache immer bei
180 grad das wird wohl funktionieren und
dann ist es braunes bis gleich ich will
das so hat probieren
dann begann das motto das ist schön
das ist etwas was auch eine party mit
brings und jeder sich anschaut und sagt
cooler pizza burger und du sagst ja habe
ich mal eben so gemacht kein problem
riechen tut er fantastisch und jetzt
wollen wir ihn auf jeden fall probieren
sie's aus dem kuchen nicht
das sieht so schön aus und der ganze
krise sterben jetzt stellen wir uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt der pizza burger aus
tv total / von den space frames
mittelhessen der teig braucht definitiv
hefe tomaten zwiebeln paprika das ding
ist einfach lecker oh mein gott
koch das nach wenn ihr das nicht nach
kocht dann seid ihr doch damit vor allem
die schön dass auch in der mitte sie ist
halt alle zutaten so leicht rauskommen
so hallo hier sind hier super lecker
wenn durch diese ganz besonders leckere
folge wie schmeckt gefallen hat dann sex
mit einem daumen hoch und wenn ihr noch
mehr rezepte aus film und serien habt
und in die kommentare rein und wenn ihr
das video von den sweatshops sehen wollt
also sie meine kramberger pizza machen
dann klickst mal da und wenn ihr den
pizza original pizza pizza bäcker bürger
sehen wollt dann klickt mal daran könnt
ihr mich abonnieren und da kommt ihr zum
ex playmate organisiert danke schön und
ich werde jetzt das ganze ding alleine
essen und dann beinen und dann mich
freuen und dann wieder wein und dann